fin tu vas voir que tu va fleurir comme
les autres toit et dans pas longtemps à
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce mimosas
qui ne fait qu'une bouchée
[Musique]
tu vas faire connaissance avec des
potions magiques du perron plantoir une
bonne base in et ça devrait être mans
j'en mettrais nous coûte de plus tu vas
voir si je vais te faire fleurir comme
les autres mois voilà la super des
supers potion magique c'est le maxi du
flore du jardinier plus oratoire qu'est
ce que tu feras à l'aide charlotte et
julien vite vite j'ai vu une chose
épouvantable
regardons d'abord par dessus le mur
[Musique]
et si ce qui s'est évanoui d'études et
le très peur il faut agir et vite
monsieur platoir mais c'est plat toi
aller bébé est là et là mais mais bon
dieu mais qu'est ce qui lui arrive
vous croyez que c'est mon produit
pourtant je suis sûr qu'il en a pas but
mais l'odeur suffit rien que l'odeur et
voit ses plates noires ou jaunes hissé à
oui je n'ai pas l'impression
mais ce qu'il ya de sûr c'est que je me
sens un peu drôle c'est bizarre même
tout bizarre
ah là là c'est l'odeur aussi vite charmé
et point que moi c'est sabine ont jetés
dans le trou là bas au spa musiciens y
est
ce qui est lourd inspirez très fort vous
aussi monsieur pernois respirer et ça va
allez vous
respirez respirer regard des musiciens
redevienne normale
aller respirer monsieur plainte war
respirer ça ne va pas alors chanté je
vais savourer hier jantes et j'ai
toujours rêvé de chanter et j'ai jamais
vu si l'on veut manger
ah ah ah ah voilà
continuez continuez encore encore choqué
mais support toi et toi tu l'as poulx
kumasi mme samira lolilol ils ont la
halle aux volumes là
[Musique]
ferry
m
[Musique]